just over a mile away from here in
Edinburgh sold tone is pan your house
pan your house was the home of the
world-renowned Scottish economist Adam
Smith in his important work The Wealth
of Nations Adam Smith argued amongst
many other things that the measurement
of a country's wealth was not just it's
gold and silver reserves
it was the totality of the country's
production and commerce I guess it was
one of the earliest descriptions of what
we now know today as gross domestic
product GDP now in the years since of
course that measurement of production
and commerce GDP has become ever more
important to the point today and I don't
believe this is what Adam Smith would
have intended that it is often seen as
the most important measurement of a
country's overall success and my
argument today is that it is time for
that to change you know what we choose
to measure as a country matters it
really matters because it drives
political focus
it drives public activity and against
that context I think the limitations of
GDP is a measurement of a country's
success is all too obvious
you know GDP measures the output of all
of our work but it says nothing about
the nature of that work about whether
that work is what whale
or fulfilling it puts a value for
example on illegal drug consumption but
not on unpaid care it values activity in
the short term that boosts the economy
even if that activity is hugely damaging
to the sustainability of our planet in
the longer term and we reflect on the
past decade of political and economic
upheaval of growing inequalities and
when we look ahead to the challenges of
the climate emergency increasing
automation an aging population then I
think the argument for the case for a
much broader definition of what it means
to be successful as a country as a
society is compelling and increasingly
so and that is why Scotland in 2018 took
the leap the initiative in establishing
a new network that called the well-being
economies governments group bringing
together as founding members at the
countries of Scotland Iceland and New
Zealand for obvious reasons were
sometimes called the CIN countries
although our focus is very much on the
common good and the purpose of this
group is to challenge that focus on the
narrow measurement of GDP to say that
yes economic growth matters it is
important but it is not all that it is
important and growth in GDP should not
be pursued at any or all cost in fact
the argument of that group is that the
goal the objective of economic policy
should be collective well-being how
happy and healthy a population is
not just how wealthy a population is and
I'll touch on the policy implications of
that in a moment but I think
particularly in the world we live in
today it has a deeper resonance
you know we focus on well-being we start
a conversation that provokes profound
and fundamental questions what really
matters to us in our lives what do we
value in the communities we live in what
kind of country what kind of society do
we really want to be and when we engage
people in those questions and finding
the answers to those questions and I
believe that we have a much better
chance of addressing the alienation and
disaffection from politics that is so
prevalent in so many countries across
the developed world today in policy
terms this journey for Scotland started
back in 2007 when we published what we
call our national performance framework
looking at the range of indicators that
we measure ourselves against and those
indicators that is varied as income
inequality the happiness of children
access to green spaces access to housing
none of these are captured in GDP
statistics but they are all fundamental
to a healthy and a happy Society and
that broader
[Music]
the broader approach is at the heart of
our economic strategy where we give
equal importance to tackling inequality
as we do to economic competitiveness it
drives our commitment to feel work
making sure that work is fulfilling and
well paid it's behind our decision to
establish a just transition Commission
to guide our path to our carbon 0
economy we know from economic
transformations of the past that if we
are not careful there are more losers
than winners and as we face up to the
challenges of climate change and
automation we must not make those
mistakes again the work we're doing here
in Scotland is I think significant but
we have much much to learn from other
countries I mentioned a moment ago our
partner nations in the well-being
network Iceland and New Zealand it's
worth noting and I will leave it to you
to decide whether this is relevant or
not that all three of these countries
are currently led by women
the clear-eyed angry white New Zealand
in 2019 publishing its first well-being
budget with mental health at its heart
Iceland leading the way on equal pay
child care and paternity rights at North
policies that we immediately think of
when we talk about creating a wealthy
economy but policies that are
fundamental to a healthy economy and a
happy Society and I started with Adam
Smith and the wealth of nations in other
Smith earlier work the more the Theory
of Moral Sentiments which i think is
just as important he made the
observation that the value of any
government is judged in proportion to
the extent that it makes its people
happy I think that is a good founding
principle for any a group of countries
focused on promoting well-being none of
us have all of the answers and no even
Scotland the birthplace of Adam Smith
but in the water would we live in today
withdrawing divides and inequalities
with disaffection and alienation it is
more important than ever that we ask and
find the answers to those questions and
promote a vision of society that has
well-being not just wealth but it's very
heart you are right now
you are right now in the beautiful sunny
capital city of the country that led the
world in the enlightenment at the
country that helped lead the world into
the Industrial Age the country that
right now is helping to lead the world
into the low-carbon age I want and I'm
determined that Scotland will also be
the country that helps change the focus
of countries and governments across the
world to put well-being at the heart of
everything that we do I think we owe
that to this generation I certainly
believe we owe that to the next
generation and all those that come after
us and if we do that let hear from the
country of the Enlightenment then I
think we create a better healthier
fitter and happier society here at home
and we play our part in Scotland in
building a fader happier world as well
thank you very much